♪ ♪
>> Greg: YOU KNOW THIS
WARRANT, NATIVE AMERICAN
PRINCESS WHO GAVE UP TRUTH
TELLING TO CASH IN ON TELLING
MORE LIES.
THE LATEST FUND-RAISING EMAIL
SHE BRINGS UP HOW SHE WAS
VISIBLY PREGNANT WHEN "THE
PRESIDENT TOLD HER THE JOB WOULD
GO TO SOMEONE ELSE."
ANOTHER STORY SHE PORTRAYS
HERSELF AS A PRESENT EFFECTING
VICTIMHOOD TO GET AN EDGE OVER
OTHERS INCLUDING REAL VICTIMS.
HOWEVER, THE PREGNANT SYSTEM
OBTAINED BY THE FREE BEACON
SHOWS THE SCHOOL OFFERED HER A
NEW CONTRACT.
SHE QUIT ANYWAY BACKING UP THE
TALE SHE TOLD BACK IN 2007 WHEN
SHE SAID SHE LEFT BY CHOICE.
OF COURSE SMALL POLITICIANS
LIED.
THOSE WHO SAY THEY DON'T ARE
LYING.
WARRANTS LIES FIT A PATTERN AND
AN OPPORTUNISTIC DECEPTION TO
DISPLAY TO A PLIGHT OF OTHERS.
IT IS NO
IN A HANDICAPPED SPACE AND
FAKING A LIMP, JESSE.
IT IS FRAUD.
[LAUGHTER]
NOW LIVES CLAIMS AMERICAN ROOTS
WAS AN HONEST MISTAKE BUT IT GOT
HER P.R. THE FIRST MINORITY
WOMAN HARVARD LAW WHICH WAS SO
HEAVILY PROMOTED BY HER AUNT
HARVARD.
SHE KNEW THAT SCHEME WASN'T
IMPLODING SHE PARADED THAT
PROCLAIMING NATIVE AMERICAN
BLOOD, BUT A TOASTER HAD MORE.
THAT WASN'T AN HONEST MISTAKE.
SO AS BIDEN GETS HIT BY UKRAINE
BOOMERANG SHE IS THE FRONT
RUNNER AND THIS NEW LIFE
MOBILITY CUSTOMER IN 2020?
PERHAPS, BUT SHE CAN JUST FLY
AGAIN AND SAY SHE WON.
I MEAN, WHOEVER DID THAT BEFORE,
RIGHT, HILLARY?
>> Jesse: SO DANA?
I NOTICED AND YOU NOTICE THE
MEDIA SIGNALING SUPPORT FOR LIZ
THROUGHOUT THIS PERIOD PLAGUING
IT DOWN, FOCUSING ON
CONSERVATIVES, POUNCING ON HER.
BEFORE POUNCING AND ACTUALLY, TO
TALK ABOUT THE VIEWER, I DON'T
THINK THIS NEW THING ABOUT
CONTRADICTIONS IN HER STORY 2007
AND 2019 PUT FORWARD BY
CONSERVATIVE.
I THINK THAT HIS RESEARCH PUT
OUT BY 2020 DEMOCRATS AND YET
THE MEDIA SAY THAT CONSERVATIVES
ARE POUNCING ON IT.
I THINK THEY SHOULD TRACE THAT
BACK AND FIND OUT WHO DID IT.
HER DEFENSES ARE GOING TO WORK
WITH THE PRIMARY VOTERS, WOMEN
THAT ARE TALKING LIKE THEY CAN
IDENTIFY WITH SOMEBODY BEING
FIRED BECAUSE I GOT PREGNANT,
EVEN IF IT'S NOT TRUE.
IN "THE NEW YORK TIMES," IN THAT
ARTICLE NOT UNTIL THE 16TH
PARAGRAPH, ACTUALLY THERE WAS A
CONTRADICTION IN THESE
DOCUMENTS.
SO I THINK SHE WON'T FEEL THE
PAIN OF ALL OF THIS UNTIL THE
FALL 2020 IF SHE DOES BECOME THE
NOMINEE.
BECAUSE THEN, REMEMBER, IT WILL
BE ABOUT CHARACTER QUESTIONS AND
EVERYBODY WILL HAVE A CHANCE TO
DECIDE.
SHE WILL PROBABLY PAY FOR IT
LATER.
>> Greg: TRUMP WILL EAT THIS
UP IF SHE BECOMES THE NOMINEE,
RIGHT?
THIS PATTERN OF PRETENDING TO BE
A VICTIM?
>> Juan: IF YOU WANT TO
PRESENT IT BUT TINA AND I
DISAGREE.
I DON'T THINK LIBERALS ARE
LEAKING INFORMATION TO THE FREE
BEACON.
>> Dana: NO, NO, THE ORIGINAL
STORY DID NOT COME FROM THE FREE
BEACON.
>> Juan: YES IT WAS.
BUT ANYWAY, I THINK TO ME, SHE'S
BEEN UNDER ATTACK FOR A WHILE.
REMEMBER THAT STORY SHE HAD A
AFFAIR WITH 24 MARINE?
>> Dana: I MISSED THAT ONE.
SPEAK TO ME TOO.
>> Juan: BECAUSE IT WAS FOCUS.
>> Greg: YOU JUST BROUGHT IT
UP.
>> Juan: IT WAS ANOTHER BOGUS
STORY.
>> Greg: DID WE EVER COVER IT?
>> Juan: I DON'T KNOW, BUT IT
WAS ALL OVER THE PAPERS COME I
WILL TELL YOU THAT.
>> Greg: IT WAS ALL OVER THE
PAPERS?
>> Dana: I READ EVERY PAPER.
>> Greg: RESEARCH COME I'M
LOOKING IT UP RIGHT NOW.
>> Juan: WEIGHT, BUT I WILL
SAY THIS.
I AM SURPRISED, PEOPLE SAY HEY,
WHAT WAS THE CONTEXT OF THIS
BECAUSE THEY SAY EVERYTHING IS
PREMATURE ON THE SCHOOL BOARD,
WE WILL RENEW YOU THE NEXT YEAR,
BUT REALIZING WE HAVE TEACHERS
SAYING TO THE REPORTERS, OH,
YEAH, THAT WAS THE POLICY, BUT
IF YOU COULD HIDE YOUR
PREGNANCY, THEN THEY WOULDN'T
KNOW.
THEY WOULD RENEW YOU.
ONCE YOU BECAME PREGNANT, HEY,
WE GOT TO HIRE SOMEONE ELSE.
>> Dana: WHY ON 2007 ON TAPE
WITH AN INTERVIEW SAYING SHE
MADE THE DECISION ON HER OWN?
IT'S HER OWN WORDS.
>> Greg: IF ONLY WE HAD A
PREGNANT WOMAN HERE TO DISCUSS.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Kimberly: SHE'S LYING.
>> Greg: HE'S IDENTIFYING AS A
PREGNANT WOMAN.
>> Dana: WE BOTH POINTED TO
JESSE.
LISTEN, SHE'S A LIAR AND A GOOD
LIAR.
>> Kimberly: I THINK SHE HAS
AN INCREDIBLE GIFT SHE'S ABLE TO
DECEIVE AND HILLARY CLINTON
DOESN'T HAVE THAT GIFT.
WHEN SHE LIED ABOUT HER EMAIL
AND LIED REPEATEDLY PEOPLE HELD
HER ACCOUNTABLE.
I DON'T KNOW IF THAT WILL WIND
UP WITH WARREN BUT I THINK IT IS
CLEAR.
DANA SAYING 100% TRUE, YOU TELL
ONE STORY AND NOW IN 2017 ON THE
CAMPAIGN TRAIL, YOU WANT TO BE
POPULAR AND CULTIVATE THE STORY.
WE TALKED TO THE LEADERSHIP OF
THE SCHOOL AT THE TIME AND I
THINK WE GET TO THE BOTTOM OF
THE STORY.
BUT I THINK IT DOES NOT MATTER.
WHEN THAT WILL THING WITH HER
HERITAGE, PURE DECEIT, SHE GOES
AND TAKES A DNA TEST AND GETS
BACKLASH FROM THE CHEROKEE
COMMUNITY.
SHE OBVIOUSLY LIED TO, 11,024TH
DISTRICT, THAT WAS RIDICULOUS
AND STILL RISING IN THE POLLS.
I DON'T KNOW IF IT IS JUST
DEMOCRATS AND DEBATES DON'T HAVE
ANYWHERE ELSE TO GO BECAUSE
JOE BIDEN IS SO DISAPPOINTING
THAT THEY DON'T CARE.
ALL RIGHT, JESSE.
>> Jesse: I WANT TO HEAR ABOUT
THIS LOVE AFFAIR WITH A MARINE.
YESTERDAY.
SPEAK I THINK THE POINT IS SHE
LIES ABOUT CORE COMPONENTS OF
WHO SHE IS, OR RACE AND HER
BABY.
SO THOSE ARE A LITTLE MORE
SIGNIFICANT WITH A LITTLE
EMBELLISHMENT.
BUT THE OTHER THING MORE
POLITICIANS HAVE MUCH MORE TO
OVERCOME BESIDES ELIZABETH
MORAN.
ELIZABETH WARREN HAD A PRETTY
GOOD.
MIDDLE-CLASS GIRL, GREAT
EDUCATION AND FIRST HUSBAND
WORKED FOR IBM, $1 MILLION IN
THE BANK PLUS AND SHE USED TO BE
A REPUBLICAN BUT NOW PURVIEW TO
THE U.S. SENATE SO SHE IS A
LITTLE INADEQUATE WHITE GUILT OR
INSECURITY, MAYBE SHE DIDN'T
HAVE TO STRUGGLE THAT OTHER
PEOPLE DID BUT LIKE YOU SAID,
SEEING THAT KARAOKE A LITTLE BIT
LOUDER TO GET AHEAD.
>> Dana: I WILL CHECK IT OUT
BUT I THINK THEY WENT TO THE
SCHOOL AND LOOKED AT THE ACTUAL